vi siete mai stupiti guardando il volo
delle lucciole
magari da bambini in vacanza qualche
calda serata estiva
sono passati trent'anni è ancora non me
ne sono stancato infatti gran parte
delle scelte della mia vita sono state
guidate dal senso di meraviglia dalla
curiosità per le cose della natura pur
essendo nato e cresciuto in una grande
città come roma io ho avuto la fortuna
di frequentare sin da bambino
le montagne in particolare dell'abruzzo
dove con la famiglia trascorreva le
vacanze
questo per me era il mio piccolo
karakorum era un non solo una muraglia
rocciosa da scavalcare ma anche un luogo
dove fantasticare sembravano così
selvaggi e distanti inospitali
in realtà sono state per millenni se il
teatro delle vicende umane e anche il
rifugio di animali straordinari altrove
scomparsi gli incontri preziosi al
cardiopalma con lupi orsi con altri
personaggi straordinari tutte queste
piccole grandi avventure vissute nelle
foreste di questa regione o nelle
montagne hanno nutrito la mia passione
questa miopia biophilia l'hanno fatta
crescere e hanno messo in me l'idea di
voler condividere con gli altri di
fermare e rendere senza tempo queste
emozioni
quindi è stato naturale che mi
avvicinassi rapidamente al linguaggio
delle immagini
c'erano immagini che dalle riviste dai
libri mi parlavano con forza avevano un
linguaggio molto potente io le
collezionare divoravo sin da bambino e
dopo un tentativo veramente maldestro
con i pennelli e con gli acquerelli che
gli è rimasto ha preso in prestito la
macchina fotografica di mio padre e non
ho più ridata indietro la fotografia
amico mi offre quel senso di libertà di
spontaneità nel guardare al mondo nel
fermare gli attimi più importanti nel
condividerlo con voi con gli altri in
pratica si tratta di realizzare quella
che è la vision è una forte idea mentale
che viene continuamente alimentato dalle
esperienze quotidiane dalle idee e dalle
intuizioni e che poi ogni tanto in modo
quasi epico va incontro
manifestazioni della natura è un
qualcosa di magico come quando questa
ombra rosso della volpe attraversato
questo quindi rinnovato su cui si
proiettavano le ombre a sua volta
azzurrine degli alberi è stata vera
magia quando la luce della luna piena
illuminato un branco di camosci
appenninici a riposo mentre le luci di
villaggi nel fondovalle molte centinaia
di metri più in basso colorano di rosa
la foschia che si stava creando tutte
queste sensazioni queste emozioni mi
hanno fatto prendere una una scelta
nella vita quella di voler rivivere il
più possibile qui in dopo una laurea in
biologia
io ho cercato il modo di trasformare
questa grande passione questa ossessione
in un lavoro ma come fare io sono
scappato a berlino città che allora era
più sexy e offriva forse più opportunità
rispetto al contesto italiano molto
fortemente negativo è scettico che
abbiamo sentito spesso dire
e qui mi sono dovuto confrontare con un
mondo di professionisti affermati dal
budget forse più corposo rispetto al mio
la possibilità da un network più
consolidato mi sono guardato attorno
c'era bisogno di una storia tra una
storia che potesse raccontare e con i
pochi mezzi che ho a disposizione
come si dice la necessità fa virtù ho
scoperto che berlino era l'habitat non
solo di 4 milioni umani ma anche di
tutta una serie di animali di specie
selvatiche vi vivevano erano situazioni
che possono raggiungere in bicicletta in
mezz'ora potevo essere sul pezzo e
quindi ho iniziato a sviluppare un
network tra tassisti poliziotti
giardinieri pensionati e mi chiamavano
come coast busters e arrivavo quando i
supermercati facevano l'offerta era il
primo a mettermi in fila insieme ai
cinghiali non scherzo in pratica se
questo progetto questa sorta di street
photography naturalistica mi ha dato
un'impostazione mi ha fatto capire di
lavorare con un'idea in testa un plot di
non cercare solo l'immagine sensazionale
ma di contestualizzarla di voler
raccontare l'intera storia
la faccio breve infine questo lavoro è
stato acquistato in toto dalla
dall'assessorato all'ambiente della
città di berlino il mio primo vero
stipendio reinvestire immediatamente
un'attrezzatura degna di tal nome
nonostante questo piccolo exploit urbano
il mio cuore batte sempre dal lato del
selvatico
quindi io rapidamente ho ripreso la
strada dei viaggi finalmente avevo il
coraggio un po più di consapevolezza nel
vedere come si diceva quanto è grande il
mondo o campeggiato sul cavo caso in
georgia
ho seguito le tracce del leopardo delle
nevi nell'himalaya indiano
ho sfruttato ogni opportunità per
guardare al mondo con gli occhi degli
altri
osservando usi e costumi degli uomini
come di altri animali senza mai però
giudicare ci sono stati tanti incontri
più o meno memorabili emozionanti alcuni
molto ravvicinati questa femmina di orso
curiosa che si alza per difendere un
piccolo nei monti tatra della slovacchia
o quello molto più sorprendente inatteso
nelle foreste di montagna dell'etiopia
con una leonessa inaspettatamente a
3.000 metri di altitudine regina della
foresta e io a piedi a guardarci negli
occhi a flirtare come uno flirt con un
gatto
un'immagine che non solo è stato uno
scoop che ha fatto il giro del mondo e
che ha portato chiaramente anche il mio
nome con sé ma che mi ha fatto tornare
in mente una cosa che ho visto già da
bambino un dipinto di russo e lì ho
capito che a volte il limite tra realtà
e fantasia è veramente labile
sottilissimo tutte queste esperienze
questo bagaglio di di di lavori di
incarichi mi hanno fatto seguire
un'altra idea folle veramente che aveva
le sue radici nella mia infanzia 30 anni
fa in un libro per bambini lesse di
questa volpe la più piccola volpe del
mondo il fennec ma dalle più grandi
orecchie bene si è trattato di
affrontare il più grande deserto del
pianeta per trovarla tempeste di sabbia
un clima così arido quasi come la mia
bocca adesso e ostacoli burocratici
zecche scorpioni una rivoluzione
la primavera araba del 2011 per portare
a casa il primo ritratto di questa
specie nel suo ambiente la vera star del
deserto scoprire anche il lato triste di
questa storia
il lato legata allo sfruttamento che se
ne fa di questo animale in queste zone
e che paga con la libertà e la sua
bellezza è un lavoro che mi ha fatto
comprendere ancora una volta il potere
che hanno le immagini per parlare a
tutti e veicolare un messaggio di
conservazione importanti dopo tutto
questo peregrinare questo giro in giro
me ne son tornato a casa direttamente in
quel abruzzo non a roma dove tutto era
nato
e mentre ammirava le mie montagne piano
piano nasceva un'idea un'intuizione una
visone epifani e quanti altri abruzzi ci
saranno in italia è possibile che sia
rimasto del selvaggio del selvatico
anche qui da noi è possibile vivere
quelle stesse avventure emozioni
esperienze perché nando questo paese
così abusato nasceva questa idea l'idea
dell'altro versante fotografi in cerca
del vero paesaggio italiano un payoff
provocatorio esiste un vero paesaggio
naturale italiano fotografi non
fotografo noi siamo lupi solitari di
solito invece questo progetto era
talmente grande e ambizioso che ha
bisogno di essere condiviso con altre
persone che presentano a mano a mano
l'idea di percorrere a passo lento la
fotografa appunto l'italia dalla vetta
del monte bianco cercando di guardarla
come fosse la prima volta senza
pregiudizi fino ai al basalto vulcanico
del montiferru in sardegna cercare di
vivere queste esperienze di condividerle
con gli altri di documentare e celebrare
le bellezze ma anche denunciare dove le
cose non ci piacciono e nato un team che
include la nostra project manager
pascalau i torelli senza la quale
veramente non saremmo andati molto
lontano e un piano d'azione e 100
missioni da realizzare in tre anni a
coprire le zone più belle sorprendenti
meno conosciute del nostro panorama del
nostro patrimonio naturale come questa e
lavora in trentino 100 missioni di una
ciascuno o di 15 giorni
ognuna che però richiede impegno
pianificazione fantasia intuizione
finanziamenti questo non difficile
trovare se ci sono idee ben accette e
tanto tanto impegno a casa come sul
campo ma che ripagano ripagano con
scoperte ed emozioni uniche scoprire la
val d'agri dell'appennino lucano che qui
sembra quasi il canada
portare al pubblico italiano tutto
questo questo percorso in questa collana
di luoghi meravigliosi ma anche al
pubblico internazionale che spesso
guarda l'italia in modo cristallizzato
un cliché sospeso tra le colline senesi
e i canali di venezia
certamente non conosce la forra
dell'abetina di rosello è proprio per
questo che noi abbiamo un bel sito web
costantemente arricchito e si dovrebbe
dell'altro versante abbiamo una presenza
sui social blog immagini raccontate
presentazioni in giro mostre e anche
altro versante tv altro versante video
un regista marco è una troupe che ci
seguono in missione non solo per
documentare il processo che porta
realizzazione di una buona fotografia ma
anche cercare di catturare il senso del
luogo dei siti che andiamo a vedere bene
mostro un breve esempio
come vi dicevo l'altro versante un
progetto multimediale collettivo in ciò
è racchiusa la propria forza
uno dei tre attori dei tre fotografie
maurizio biancarelli umbro da 30 anni
veterano della fotografia naturalistica
italiana sicuramente il saggio del
gruppo il suo logo di lezioni sono i
misteriosi monti sibillini tra umbria e
marche di cui lui sicuramente conosce
ogni angolo e ha forse la documentazione
più ampia
maurizio ha uno spiccato senso per
ascoltare le voci di un luogo per
capirne cogliere il potere evocativo e
ciò lo porta a frequentare anche zone
piuttosto difficile raggiungere i monti
alburni in campania o il bosco di
sasseto nel lazio che sembra quasi
uscire dalle favole
qui parliamo veramente di slow fotografi
un sano antidoto pro o contro la valanga
di immagini che ci raggiunge ogni giorno
è anche un modo di guardare diversamente
alla nostra realtà
maurizio riuscito a tornare persino una
stonehenge in sicilia le rocche di arge
moscow questi megaliti di arenaria che
non dalle forme vagamente zoomorfe
antropomorfe che sembra racchiudere in
sé delle storie delle leggende e un
senso di soprannaturale che per fare
questa zona è uno dei tanti territori
dove le storie dell'uomo e quelle della
della terra si vengono a incrociare
oppure il sasso simone nel montefeltro
marchigiano dove pensate nella seconda
metà del 1500 giovane cosimo medici
aveva progettato la sua città ideale la
città del sole l'hanno costruita sforzo
mostruoso variata la piccola era
glaciale i freddi inverni sempre più
freddi ne hanno determinato l'abbandono
adesso non rimane più nulla
last but not least il terzo attore del
gruppo e luciano gaudenzio fotografo
friulano di grande competenza e gusto
estetico a suo agio veramente in tutte
le condizioni to riesce a cogliere la
bellezza in situazioni dove anche la
follia dell'uomo ha creato distruzione
che vedete la diga del vajont e la
tragedia del longarone dopo una nevicata
luciana è cresciuta all'ombra delle
dolomiti friulane
è lì che si è formata scattato forse le
sue immagini più conosciute ha creato un
volume dedicato a quelle che definisce
le voci del silenzio a una tale
competenza con la luce con il clima da
essere al posto giusto al momento giusto
come questa immagine
nella foresta del cansiglio dove lo
reato veramente nel momento opportuno
sa quando vogliono opportunità sa quando
capisce che non c'è più tempo e quindi
uno stormo di firme dal pin di solito in
perenne movimento sosta un attimo una
bufera di neve oppure le cime del gruppo
del cimone che ha tra veneto e trentino
che si affacciano la porzione di attesa
a causa di nebbie maltempo è disposto a
tutto
immagini che non si improvvisano
appendersi addirittura un'imbragatura
per per fotografare dolomiti del brenta
dall'alto come non ha mai visto nessuno
a camminare migliaia di metri dislivello
per sorelle nubi nelle vette feltrine in
veneto e poi a fotografare un gioco di
luci tra il sole e le nebbie addirittura
uscendo dai confini nazionali e quindi
dalla slovenia guardare all'italia
gruppo del mangart che sono le immagini
che cerchiamo immagini che fanno sognare
che raggiungono il cuore e che vengono
il nostro messaggio di sensibilizzazione
del progetto in pratica in tutto questo
percorso le montagne stanno rivelando le
proprie storie con un sussurro bisogna
andare a passo lento in punta dei piedi
per ascoltarle la maiella appare dalle
nebbie e fa capire che il paesaggio è
fatto da chi ci vive che sia una
piantina apparentemente poco
appariscente questa e land rosaci
abruzzese pensare in tutto il mondo che
c'e solo su alcune rocce di questa
montagna e dalla sua storia tanto
importante quanto quella dell'ultimo
pastore che da sessant'anni porta le
pecore oltre 2.000 metri di quota sulla
stessa majella alcune montagne hanno in
sé una storia triste l'ho capito dal
silenzio artificiale soffocante
dell'ortigara in veneto dove si
combattono delle battaglie più efferate
della storia della prima guerra mondiale
nello stesso gruppo di montagna
altipiano di asiago chinando mi ad
ascoltare la voce di questo piccolo
esserino per alcuni indici non
importante insignificante quasi
disgustoso la salamandra di aurora
queste realtà uno dei veri tesori della
nostra terra
ner esistono pochissime in veramente una
manciata di ettari di questo bosco che
viene tagliato per usi boschivo chiede
solamente di rallentare di ascoltare
questa storia un altro animale sta
perdendo terra terreno scusate la
gallina prataiola che mette in scena
questo spettacolo di danza del maschio
per corteggiare la femmina nelle steppe
della sardegna occidentale
ma fino a quando questo tipo di ambiente
parlando rapidamente queste stesse
alberate piene di fiori però non sono un
ambiente intatto vergine sono il
prodotto di millenni di convivenza con
l'uomo perché sono nate dalla pastorizia
da un uso forse più lungimirante meno
pesante del territorio e questo è quello
che abbiamo capito da questo progetto
che il vero paesaggio italiano è un
unicum creato da la storia dell'uomo e
quella della terra questo forse è il
risultato della del nostro lavoro
qualche mese fa nella mia ultima
missione in valcamonica e lombardia
di fronte a queste meravigliose
incisioni rupestri scolpite 6000 anni fa
da mani abili ho capito che non facciamo
altro che portare avanti un lavoro
intrapreso dall uomo decine di migliaia
di anni fa quello di raccontare con
meraviglia con senso di stupore quello
che è questo nostro legame con la terra
di cui noi italiani ci siamo dimenticati
ma che dovremmo riscoprire e essere
custodi più attenti grazie